ffmpeg and open source command line tool
for processing audio and video files it
was created by Fabrice Bullard in the
year 2000. the name stands for Fast
Forward followed by the moving picture
experts group file format today it's
used in a wide variety of tools like
Google Chrome and blender as well as
video platforms like YouTube and Vimeo
it's able to decode encode transcode
Multiplex D Multiplex stream filter and
play virtually any multimedia file in
the world with over 100 different codecs
supported it works by taking an input
file that then passes it to a d
multiplexer that splits the audio and
video tracks into separate encoded data
packets these packets are then decoded
into uncompressed frames which can be
further processed and filtered you might
modify the brightness and contrast add
subtitles or visualize the audio as a
waveform then finally these frames are
encoded and multiplexed back into the
output file in addition it also comes
with the FF play tool to easily play
media from the command line and FF probe
to extract metadata from the file in
addition to tons of low-level libraries
for develop developers building their
own multimedia processing software to
get started install it then open up the
terminal use the ffmpeg command followed
by I to supply one or more input files
to convert that file to a different
format simply provide the name of the
output it will automatically detect the
file extension and convert it to the
proper codec or the C flag can be used
to specify an explicit codec like mpeg-4
for the video track and mp3 for the
audio you may also want to change the
quality of the output file the B flag
can change the bitrate while the r flag
can change the frame rate and S can
change the resolution in some cases you
may have multiple video clips that need
to be combined together these clips can
be listed in their own text file then
combined together by specifying the
format as concat and the codec as copy
copy can also be used to make
modifications to a video like when used
with t to trim a certain number of
seconds off of the video footage but the
most powerful option might be VF which
creates a filter graph that can handle
Transformations like rotation and
scaling and color modifications like
brightness and contrast in addition to
many other effects and if you have an
SRT file for captions in your video
ffmpeg is able to convert it to an ass
file which can then be used with the VF
option to easily add subtitles to your
video if this has been ffmpeg in 100
seconds hit the like button for more
short videos like this thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one